[Music]
this
is star talk sports edition and today's
topic is
gambits and game theories
you gotta you gotta love it and who do i
have of course my intrepid co-hosts
chuck nice jack hey hey neil all right
very good you are not the professional
athlete in this group
i would go to gary o'reilly for that
that's right
gary what's up now none of us have any
particular
competitive expertise in the stuff we're
going to talk about today
we're going to talk about game theory
we're going to talk about 21st century
chess
uh and there's a lot going on there do
is it a sport do we bring it into the
olympics or
are computers beating us what's going on
so we had to bring in an expert
okay and so we're bringing in
dr jonathan shaffer jonathan welcome to
star talk
all right you're a professor in the
computer
computing science department at the
university of alberta canada formerly
you were dean there
but you quickly stepped down i think
wisely so now you can actually
get some work done right this is how
that works
all right uh and we have on record here
that you created
a computer program called chinook this
is now 25 years ago
that became the world champion of
american checkers
okay correct okay now checkers you know
but that's not chess
right so as as as checkers is often
disparaged by that comparison
yeah yeah yeah that guy's playing
chuckers not
chad i'm just that's right that's right
that's what i'm just i'm just saying
but uh what what i'd like to specially
is uh you're also behind the program
polaris i get that right great name by
the way
um how to get in good with every
astronomer in the room
uh that plays the uh texas holdem poker
so for me that's so that's uh even uh
more intriguing but tell me
what what kind of work have you been
involved in with ai and
game solving
well of course i'm doing research in ai
and uh
when i was young i wanted to be the
world chess champion i mean bobby
fischer
was my my role model when i was young
but a lack of talent and an interesting
girl sort of got in the way
and so i turned to ai to realize my
dreams
i couldn't be world champion let my
computer program
be the world champion so that led to
you know building world champion caliber
programs and checkers
uh and poker and a variety of other
games and so i'm a very competitive
person
when i start one of these projects we
want to win and
i don't let human egos get in the way of
trying to build superhuman game plan
right so what you're saying is you
weren't
you weren't as good in chess as you
wanted to be as inspired as you were
by bobby fischer so you started writing
software and code that could beat not
only you
could kick your own ass basically
he was like you know if i can't be the
best i'm gonna make the thing that's
gonna be the best
and then by proxy
so this is in movies right they're
saying oh you want to kick my ass away
first you have to kick my robot's ass
that's how this works but you know chuck
chuck to your point one of the most
traumatic moments in my life
was working on my chest program and i'm
a chess master
and the day that it finally beat me i
almost
cried and cheered with the likes
yeah you know what i i i know that
feeling i have it every time i have an
argument with my 14 year old son
and lose
[Laughter]
darth vader skywalker moment
yeah but it could also be it's very sort
of pygmalion right it's like
your creation um you fall did you fall
in love with your
program no that's right that's another
that's a different ai program you're
working on
that's the robot girlfriend young lady
that got him
interested in something else you just
asked the chess master that question
and you saw his move there didn't you
just so a couple of years back we i had
uh maurice ashley the chess grand master
american grand master come to uh he
visited
i i forgot whether he was in town or we
nabbed him or
i forgot how we got him into my office
but
a chess grandmaster and i i asked him
about uh bobby fisher
and what it is to get a machine
to learn how to play chess do you learn
the way bobby fischer learned or the
other rules let's find out
what he said grandmaster maurice ashley
was fisher innovatively brilliant
because nobody trained him
and he had to figure it all out on his
own so therefore he came
out of someplace else because had he
been formally trained everyone would
know
he learned these moves that way and that
and if you come from somewhere else
if you're self-taught nobody knows how
to play you
is there some of that in there i think
there is some of that in there fisher
was his own freak i mean he had his own
genius
and his main forte in addition to being
immensely gifted was his work ethic
he studied everything looked at
everything looked at
other languages so that he could read
stuff in russian
he was incredibly gifted at just
consuming
information and then him being himself
he would on top of that he would just
add his own twist to it
and the right you have to realize the
whole soviet school was pitted against
them
they wanted to destroy this upstart and
they knew it
from when he was 14 15 16 years old
i mean this was this was a a star in the
firmament that targeted spotted
and said that kid can play and you know
it doesn't take much
i don't care what country you're from or
race you're from
gender you name it you start playing
chess moves and chess players are like
this person will kick your ass watch out
and they knew it from when he was young
and he was bent on taking them down
because he was
he was a perfectionist and he wanted to
play against the best so
that drive that energy was was unmatched
was unparalleled
maybe maybe kasparov we could argue
matches matches that kind of focus but
there's very few players in the history
of chess that had that
burning desire to simply eviscerate you
and that was fisher and and he said it
he just
he loves that moment battle terms that's
that was that's
crush and destroy you i will eviscerate
you that is that's just a word
on the board oh no oh no you know
i gotta go what this is talking about
chess is chess is life and that's that's
a direct quote from fisher
so jonathan uh if if bobby fischer was
sort of a perfect
learning machine uh today
in modern sort of aai models are they
perfect learning machines like
bobby fischer is he some some system
some method and operation to follow or
has ai found even more clever pathways
to success
well humans are fundamentally different
than computers and they do things very
differently
bobby fischer was absolutely remarkable
what he did
in in the span of time that he was on
the top of this game is
is incredible but what we learned
from experience is that if you feed
human knowledge into ais
they don't play as well as if they can
learn on their own take a look at damn
that's cold
i was gonna say it just makes perfect
sense though
but it does in a way and if you take a
look at the alpha zero chess program
it starts off with just the rules of the
game
and then it plays against itself it's a
very lonely experience but it plays
against itself
millions of times and it becomes
superhuman and not only does it
superhuman
it plays chess in a way that is so
different than humans do
that we can actually learn from these
ais
the nice thing about these ais though is
that they don't have an ego
they're not going to make a snide remark
when they they beat you
um and well they're completely different
during the game actually in my first
chess program that's exactly what i did
because well there's a competitive
spirit behind the facade of uh an air
oh man that's so cool oh why didn't you
leave that
in there i want so badly to give
somebody because you know these chess
programs are immensely popular right now
and
you know they have some of the free
versions online
where you can get like the beginner
versions and you'll
i guess that's how they kind of suck you
in they give you the beginner version
for free
and then you like you play that and then
uh you move up
but it would be so great just to have
that
program saying things like that's all
you got
or oh no
you've got to give him the
schwarzenegger terminator voice
oh well so now now you've got to up the
game and
and sort of characterize the voice and
have certain movie characters to come in
there and just
then you can to bishop trash
you're going down
[Laughter]
you know who you want to do next wait so
jonathan you said it plays millions of
games
how quickly can it play a million games
against itself yeah very quickly
and the reason is because these
computers are operating at the speed of
light
you know the human brain is amazing but
it's incredibly slow
when bobby fischer plays chess he's
analyzing roughly two chest positions
per second
which is fast for humans but slow by
computers
take a look at deep blue we all know who
deep blue is chess program
built in 1997 which defeated by ibm
yeah ibm's blue 1997 technology that's
23 years ago
that program was looking at two hundred
million chess positions per second
compared to gary kasparov's too you know
what's amazing that the media doesn't
get it right people
are stunned when they say oh computers
are better than
humans and i say well that's not such an
interesting technology story what's much
more interesting
is that the humans withstood the
technological onslaught
of computers for as long as they did
because when you look at those numbers
the computers have an enormous speed
advantage
well wait so so computers are better
well what okay let me let me
slice it let me thread a needle here are
computers better than us
because they're faster than us are they
better than us because
they are more clever because if they're
simply faster
of course they're faster all right i'm
not going to you know take i'm not going
to find the square root of an
eight-digit number on my own give it to
the damn computer
all right so so can you tell me that the
ai
is coming from a whole other place in
where it's going
so the ai is two things or as our human
chess players their search and knowledge
and humans do search very slowly they
only look at two positions at a time
computers can go millions of times
faster and that's a huge advantage
humans make up for the search by
knowledge
gary kasparov can tell you amazing
things about chess
my ais maybe not so much and so
most of those million moves are not
interesting and and an expertise
there's a majority of the moves an
overwhelming majority of the rooms that
are immaterial they're ruled out right
away
right so yeah but if you're building an
ai
that's uh um got all these speed
advantages
costs nothing to look at all these moves
and yeah 99
of them are are bad but if you don't
look at all of them you might
miss something really good when you talk
about pattern recognition and machine
learning as opposed to actual
intelligence that human beings possess
which is an actual
the same type of thing but executed
differently
in a chess program has there ever been
the computer that has come up
with the innovation so
it's wow look at that
nobody's ever thought of that chuck
that's that's what jonathan said it said
they play the game completely
differently
as a result of they haven't explored all
the parameter space
and they find all these amazing things
that humans never even
thought of looking at or quite frankly
humans
overlooked so jonathan is fake if we've
got this powerful
speed freak of ai could it then go away
and bring together or bring forward
something like nash's equilibrium
or is it just going to deliver in a
certain way but not create
things like that that will allow to roll
out into all sorts of different areas
what's
what's not what's nasty yeah what is
game equilibrium
i i don't come chuck do we have to
explain exactly that's why i'm here
so you guys can explain everything to me
no what is what is next so more more
hold up more broadly what role does game
theory play
and and which is how and when and why
you might even find a nash equilibrium
in the middle of it
so this one type of game is called a
perfect information game it's like chess
and checkers
at every point in the game you know
exactly what's going on you know where
the pieces are you know whose turn it is
you have complete information
there's another kind of game called
imperfect information
that's where some of the information is
hidden that's like a game like poker
where
you know your cards but you don't know
your opponent's cards
john nash came out oh by the way that
would include even bridge
where you're playing with someone but
you don't know their cards even though
you're on the same side
right right um but um
let's stick to poker because i think
more people um
understand that the the real concept of
poker which is fundamental concept which
is bluffing
which is a really important concept in
uh
in poker and uh what nash came up with
was this brilliant idea that
in these imperfect information games you
can get to a point where
everybody has a strategy they can follow
and everybody breaks even
and if you deviate from that strategy
you're going to lose and so this nash
equilibrium is something that
um it's quite surprising uh john nash
uh got the nobel prize for it
in economics that's right and and many
of your listeners may may
recognize john nash from the amazing
movie called a beautiful mind
which details his his at times tragic
life
what's interesting though about this
this nash equilibrium since you bring it
up
is that uh people think of poker as
being a
a game of deception and bluffing and it
is
but the reality is is that uh that's a
human concept
and the ais remember when we talked
about chess they play very differently
they play almost alien-like
in terms of how they play chess but when
it comes to poker
my poker programs have no knowledge of
bluffing or deception
it turns out that it all falls out in
the mathematics and so when you take
the mathematical area of game theory the
nash's equilibrium and you use these
concepts in your program
you get bluffing and deception for free
and
the net result is you get poker playing
programs they can
just like in chess can beat all humans
so you don't need to teach them how to
read a tell or a facial micro expression
i mean listen because you're playing
that you're playing the percentages at
all times you're playing the math
it doesn't make a difference why do i
care what your face looks like if i know
that you have a four percent probability
of having a particular hand
i'm going to bet that four percent
because i have a 96 percentage no no no
no no no that's not it it's whether
there's a four percent chance he had the
hand that was well that's what
i mean well no okay no i i want you to
have the pan that i will lose
neil i'm just clarifying yeah for
precision here yeah okay so i wait i'm
very fascinated by this what you're
saying is this
notion that i'm gonna read you know i'm
gonna they're gonna wear dark sunglasses
so you can't see their eyes so they
can't see their emotions so they can't
see this
you're saying that ai playing ai
will bluff without having to read
anybody's body language
yeah that's correct that's so cool
that's uh that's freaking amazing
so the cool thing is not only will they
bluff they'll do it well
if you watch the world championships of
poker they have an
ai playing along with the game that's
being played
so that you can actually see all of the
mathematical probabilities and
percentages of each hand
so that you can see how well the
actual human players are playing against
one another
as opposed to the measure of of an
ai and i think it makes it it's the only
reason i watch
so so jonathan we gotta bring this
segment to a close but just
let's just i got one question let's keep
this guy
this is fascinating stuff he's our new
best friend
new best friend right oh you because you
want to win some poker games
i would be offended if my poker face
wasn't
you gonna lose you don't lose
i'm afraid i will just have to use my
best arnold schwarzenegger takedown
and put you in your place so
are you working on any programs now to
beat something in the future that we're
gonna you're gonna show up in the news
uh right now no i'm working on some
fundamental problems to do with games
but
not to build superhuman uh game playing
programs
okay so what i like is you know we do
games game the whole gaming
universe is rising up in everyone's
awareness especially ours
and so uh if we can bring you back to
talk about other
games that show up that'd be great to
have you as our sort of
man at arm's reach
i'm really good at rolling the dice i
practiced a lot
all right so so jonathan it's been
delight to have you on we will
definitely
find an excuse to bring you back since
you're
apparently you're our best friend now
for the biggest reason
all right uh jonathan thanks for joining
us and we'll we'll be back
shortly on star talk sports edition
gambits
and game theory
we're back star talk sports edition
gambits
and game theory and in this segment
we're going to focus on
the chess in the 21st century you know
chess
brings back all these images of like old
crusty men playing at
tables and things and i think that
that's been
changing of late and so
i in this segment i want to sort of
broaden this out but before we do so let
me reintroduce my
co-host chuck nice johnny hey chuck
chuck
what's that shirt you're wearing you got
that i kind of recognize
it says science is true whether
or not you believe in it i i've heard of
that quote
as well you resemble that quote
yes yeah no so this is a cool new star
talk shirt that uh
okay i don't even have one yet okay no
yes so
uh you got on the early list for that i
did okay
i i got this and uh i got it along with
a vaccine so i'm just good now
oh he pretended he was 90 years old and
stepped ahead of some little old lady
yeah no uh but yeah you you can pick
these up now you can order these now
people
look at that and it's really cool i mean
i will put a link in it i hadn't i
haven't seen it yet so that's a
you're doing this behind my back very
gary yes
always good to have you ma'am thank you
my friend okay i love your sports sense
so here's with it none of us play chess
or we do we're probably not good at it
so we needed somebody who had some
street cred in this at all so we've got
somebody
who won the girls nationals u.s girls
nationals at age
15. okay all right currently ranked
women's feed a master okay that's a
title
all right add your host uh she's host of
boates live all right on twitch
alongside her
kids sister andrea and she's a
24 year old trash talking chess player
and in the internet influencer
alexandria botez alexander welcome to
star talk
thank you so much for having me i'm
super excited
hi excellent excellent i got to ask you
that like the perfunctory questions like
what got you interested in chess let's
get these out of the way so so
give us a give us a short history of
your interest in chess yeah so
traditionally in the us chess has been
seen as a game for
nerds but in eastern europe it's a game
for everyone
and my parents came from romania where
there was a very heavy chess culture so
my dad actually started teaching me when
i was six
oh okay so this is just that's like here
like you go out with your kids and
and play ball with him in the backyard
then they set you up in front of a
chessboard man that's badass okay
yeah exactly i mean all of the kids have
to do it it's just kind of a rite of
passage
wait wait but but but but you didn't
reject it so not everyone is going to
embrace it so what's wrong with
you he wanted to eat
oh chuck there's a window on your
parenting skills
i mean he's not wrong
um actually i think it started just
because
i was super competitive which i got from
my dad
so he actually wanted to troll my mom
uh who didn't play very much chess and
he said
i'm gonna teach my six-year-old daughter
how to play and i bet she can beat you
in two weeks
oh the trash talking is in the house
so it's in the blood yeah like this so
when i say things it's not my fault
it's been ingrained since a young age
you know
all right so all right so you that's
your baptism your chest baptism
but wait wait two weeks later i beat you
what
happened an opening trick i mean think
of the terminator coming into chess with
like a four move tactical combination he
remembered and then i just got lucky and
my dad just will never let my mom forget
that's so easy so you beat your mother
[Laughter]
let's take a peek at uh my next clip
with maurice
ashley because i asked him what did it
take to make it
to the top of the game like what what
happened in his life
what what generally what is required for
this to happen let's check it out
you've made a strong case for being
possessed in your early days
in your love for chess can someone reach
international grand master
just simply by studying but not being
completely possessed by it
no real no you cannot become an
international group
that means all the international grammar
there's something a little different
about him
absolutely absolutely to to
want to be a grand master of chess
i think you know malcolm gladwell talks
about ten thousand hours
that's not enough i mean you have to
have like ten thousand games
yeah forget the ten thousand hours you
you have to have the passion
you have to have the will you have to
have the determination you have to have
the desire
uh to study that much to put in that
amount of data into your brain
and on top of it you have to have the
thickest skin
to tolerate being humiliated over and
over
on your way to the top i've seen many
talented
young players players or people say he's
got the gift
he's the next bobby fisher he's the next
lifestyle they get
from there and you can see that they're
excellent players but the moment
they get to a level where they start
getting punched in the nose
and they can't quite win as easily as
they did
back in the young days they suddenly
start to
feel a little less comfortable and
suddenly the game's not as much fun
and suddenly they don't want to do it as
much and that struggle to get
past that critical point has stopped
many
a prodigy i think that happened to my
son because he was
he beat people easily throughout
elementary school middle school
bad thing to do into high school and he
started beating me
when he was 12 and by the time he was 14
i would take one game out of 30
from him and then he goes into high
school tournaments
and now like national tournaments and
then you start seeing
people his age even younger and it's
like oh it's not so easy anymore it's
not so
you know and and and i think
the effort that it actually requires
to be the best had eluded him
all those previous years and so i think
he might have been a casualty
in just the way you described yes i
don't know that that's what happened to
him
but but that happens to a lot of young
people
they especially when it comes easy you
know that one of those things things
should not come too easily
you're gifted but you shouldn't you
shouldn't feel like oh come on i'm going
to beat everyone
because it takes so much work and the
thing is
everybody at the top is gifted every
last one of them is tremendously gifted
no matter
which one of those players magnus
carlsen happens to be
the best of the best of the best but
everyone after him
is a freak and they all have to work
really hard extremely hard to
maintain that level because there's some
kid who's 16 years old in china right
now
who everybody's pointing at is saying
he's the next one
and china's got a billion people right
and then they're knocking on the door
and you're sitting at the top like man
i'm trying to hold on to this title
i'm trying to be one of the best because
as soon as that player comes up
you're gonna somebody is going to get
replaced
wow so alexandra so are you weirdly
obsessed possessed are you and are you
like thoroughly depressed now after that
i am not a grand master i'm a master
so just a man
why do we look at her why are we even
talking to her
why are we wasting our time here guys
she's just a master
all right but so so tell us what level
of
weird preoccupying obsession
has to descend upon people or does it it
absolutely does you have to live and
breathe
chest there's moments in your life where
it's your number one
priority and to end up being a
professional chess player
is worse than becoming a struggling
artist
i just feel like it's worse actually i'm
sure artists also
have it pretty bad but the point is
there's not a lot of money in chess
unless you're in the top 10 in the world
so you're only doing it because of your
pure obsession
and compa being competitive for the sake
of being the
best so you have to have a very strong
why
to why you play wow so
so just to restate what you just said
you're saying in so many other
professions there's a lot of money
awaiting people who are all really good
at it
but here the money's only awaiting the
very few so you got you're not driven by
money yeah exactly it's a pure
passion sport gee okay
uh no so so so okay
in in the words of a uh
soon to be former president why would
you do it
i actually think that's the question and
that was one thing
that really changed my trajectory
because when i won girls nationals i got
offered a full ride to
um be on the chess team at university of
texas and
okay that's a reason that is a good
reason okay there's some
that money in there reason but it would
also mean that that would be my number
one priority
and i realized that if i wanted to do
chess that's
all i could ever do and for me that
wasn't a compelling why
i'm much more passionate about things
like making really good content for
chess and getting the average person
into it
which i think is so beneficial and so
inspiring that that's why i switched
more
to um the content side of things so you
you see being more of an ambassador for
the game the sport the endeavor whatever
anybody's going to call it we'll get to
whether or not it's a sport i'm sure at
some point
so i don't want to i don't want to be i
don't want to chime in right there
but is it is the ambassadorship where
your passion is that's what you feel is
uh
because i think that that's you know
based on what we were
listening to with maurice i mean you're
talking about an extremely
high uh litmus
for anybody to to to pass
in terms of uh that kind of dedication
there are very few people who have that
kind of dedication
to anything so that's right
that's right that's right we look at
edison talking about how much he worked
right right yeah no one is saying oh
he's just naturally broke that boy
he worked his ass off so so alexandra
are you so what you're saying is um some
of your chess
energy that might just be purely
put into chess you are also spreading
into
um as as as chuck said becoming an
ambassador for the sport
raising the awareness level just to
increase the health of the sport
in general is that that is now a
priority is my
my biggest priority right now and i had
to have that switch because i know what
it's like to be obsessed with chess
and that's what got me to the level that
i'm at right now but i think it's also
extremely fascinating to be able to
explain these difficult concepts to
people who maybe never would have been
into the game otherwise
at all and and what's helping you of
course is the he
the the runaway success of the queen's
gambit
on netflix um we we
made time for that sought maybe within
two days of when it posted
but all anecdotal evidence suggests that
i mean from from the sales of
of chess boards over the holidays to the
chatter that's going on
and the membership and the number of
total games played
uh that's had a real effect on things i
mean the two of you right
yeah i mean the queen's gambit success
has absolutely bled into all types of
chess events and chess content and chess
um equipment like boards so it's been
super exciting to see chess where wait
gary
did you hear she used the word bled
that's very
warm oh no it didn't spill overflow
no you bled we've already heard
maurice ashley talk about evisceration
okay
anyone thinks this is this is tea and
tea biscuits it's as simple as
i want to sell more chess boards we'll
bleed into it this
is pretty this is pretty yeah i mean all
right
we we are looking at brutality
okay we want to be clear yeah i didn't
want that to go by without somebody
other than me
noticing okay keep going alexander all
right you won't make me bleed my own
blood isn't that one of the months
you gotta think of super passionate
chess players nobody ever
cared about this game when i was growing
up it was nerdy
people made fun of it and now all of a
sudden it's a number one hit on netflix
you never have a moment like this as a
chess
enthusiast in your entire life so we're
just all trying to
make the most of it and are so excited
to see regular try to surf
i think you're right to ride this wave
because what i hear is
parcheesi is on your heels
you know what's what's that catches on
forget about it
that that new netflix show about the
part cheesy champion
oh man i'm intimidated already
so the thing the thing is alexandra you
look at
your sport and then being 20 something
you see it through your natural lens of
digital
social media she's a 21st century
person right yeah and she's going to
look at it and say this thing needs to
be
electrified let's establish this let's
establish this clearly
all right so you're 24 going on 25 turn
but just recently okay so what it means
is
you barely have a memory
of the 20th century if all if you are a
normal human right
because our earliest memories are one
with four
typically if you're really precocious
maybe three exactly but basically
between three and five so
that so the 20th century is some is
you are all made branded made in the
21st century
so what is that doing to chess because i
don't want to
entirely credit the queen's gambit uh
netflix series for this because you're
out there
you got a huge following yeah you got p
and you tr
the fun with you and your sister you
know i caught some of those
you know it's just fun to just to watch
the confusion
right and and it's fun confusion because
there's always an objective there
so you i'm not you can't tell me you're
not a participant on this landscape
yeah i mean it's made me shift
how i prioritize what we're doing with
chess
before it was all about accuracy it's a
game of perfect information
all you're trying to optimize is for the
most accurate play that's your number
one goal
but now with um playing online
when you're playing fast games it's not
just about accuracy
it's also about playing trickier things
that are hard to calculate in a specific
time
and then when you add an audience on top
of that the number one goal
is making it either entertaining or
educational or if you're talented both
okay let's see what maurice ashley had
to say because i asked him about the
21st century chess
and this interview is only a couple
years old but let's find out what he
tells us
i think that chess has definitely
married well with the 21st century it's
now a big online game
everybody goes online and plays
everybody all over the world you can
just get online
and playing these internet chess clubs
and chess.com and
all these great sites and you just go on
and you play players from all over the
world
and i think that you're right there is
something that's lost in that
face-to-face
personal mono amano and also just the
interaction between
people at a board but at the same time
it also does something enhanced because
the game has gotten much more
international and if i'm i'm a kid in
brooklyn i could get online and be
playing
some kid in south africa or in tokyo
or in australia just like that
what's to stop someone getting online
because there's not a picture of you
there
you're just this probably a name handle
what's to stop someone from attaching a
computer to the other side and then you
end up playing the computer
absolutely nothing absolutely nothing
the only thing that stops them is their
integrity
and if there's a deficit of that then
you're going to be playing against a
computer
and that's it i think there's i mean
clearly there's some people who do that
but most people are online to have a
good time
and you can pretty much very quickly see
when someone's playing
a little out of their league and
most people just want to have fun so
very rarely do they cheat so so
alexandra what
maurice is not imagining here because
he's saying 21st century you're
exploiting the electronics of the
internet and the web
what he's not imagining is turning that
activity
into a spectator sport which is what
you've done right i mean
nobody expected that for games either it
seemed a little bit counterintuitive for
anybody to enjoy watching somebody else
play a game
play video games which is huge right
yeah um
and when you think about it it's kind of
similar to sports um
why would you watch sports instead of
just play it yourself because you're
looking at the people who are the best
at this particular game and it's really
entertaining and you learn more from it
you get inspired
and chess is now having a very
similar uprising on the internet where
all of a sudden people think it's
entertaining or educational to watch
so that's it you do you you emulate your
heroes neil
you know as a young boy growing up
watching soccer i wanted to be pele i
wanted to be the world's greats
and emulate them right did you do the
back the backwards
fl bicycle kick into the goal yeah but i
missed the ball
pretty much you did the move
you just missed the ball yeah and maybe
i wasn't as naturally blessed as i
imagined
um all i look at when we when we listen
to alexandra is
you know chess may be becoming the new
rock and roll but am i looking at the
new lead singer here oh wow
that's very flattering are you talking
about neil
oh yeah yeah yeah he needs me to flatter
him right
i mean it's really weird to even think
that but yeah i mean i've definitely
become
one of the most well-known female chess
figures and i think that's what it
usually goes like
with um the intersection of social media
in any sport
it's the person who is good at that
sport but also
very good at spreading content and
learning how to reach a wide audience
so and that's what i don't think maurice
was imagining as a 21st century
um manifestation of chess and so
right so so this this is interesting so
alexandra you could have birthed an
entire uh an entire stratum
of chess enthusiasts where uh well you
could be spoiling them because they
think this is what chess is
if they get really good and they go to
the international contest and there's
the russian across the table
now they just want to smack talk it and
that you're not supposed to do that
that's true but i actually wonder what
the desires of the average person is
because
anyone can play in an over the board
tournament and they can enjoy it because
they are also going to get matched with
people who have a similar ranking to
them
but for the hobbyist now you can enjoy
chess just by playing it online so maybe
it's going to be a difference where
people are playing
the most chess ever online before
they've even ever played a game that
lasts over two hours which is insane wow
wow that's just a difference we've been
discussing
strategies and nash equilibrium with
professor
with dr schaefer and here i'm listening
to
a chess master whose strategies are very
much 21st century
i want to trash someone i'm actually
going to illustrate my moves
as i play so there's an educational part
of it
there's a time if you play blitz that
you will play complicated moves
so as that person has to calculate in a
short space of time
this is evil by the way just so as
everyone knows that's how i think about
it
because i can't play chess but this is
strategy all the same
and alexandra seems to be working it to
her own device
her own advantage we got to take a break
but when we come back we'll get into her
gameplay
and just find out because alexander we
saved
part three for just sort of shoot the
right so
i just want to get into so what your
tactics are and and
how successful are they and what role do
you have your sister your kids
sister playing in all of this so we're
gonna take a quick break
this is star talk sports edition gambits
and
game theory when we return
we're back star talk sports edition
we're talking about
gambits and game theory as applied to
chess
and i got chuck chuck hey hey always
there gary
hey neil you're helping me do this and
we have to bring in someone who had
at least some expertise in chess on like
the three of us
and so we went straight to the internet
top at
alexandra botez alexandra welcome to
star talk this is our
third segment we were just trying we
just unscripted just try to
uh learn some stuff uh free association
but what why is there there's a
particular kind of gambit
associated with you in particular what
is that that's called
botez gambit a botanist game well first
tell me what a gambit is just i will but
for those listening don't try these at
home
don't try these all right you can put
your eye out
don't try this at your own risk um so
gambits are usually
when you give up some material for
some kind of compensation that is along
the lines of peace activation so say you
give a pawn
and even though you're down upon your
pieces are going to be more active so it
usually feels
fair oh i see so so sacrificing for
an advantage or sacrificing to
disadvantage yeah sometimes you
disadvantage yourself that's what mine
does
okay so the boat test gambit is what now
so ah
you know it's a little bit embarrassing
but when you play
chess that lasts only 60 seconds you
make a lot more mistakes
and i kept accidentally what kind of
chess is 60 second chance it's called
bullet so the entire game can't last
longer than two minutes
wow yeah so one minute for each exactly
right okay yeah
um and i kept blundering my queen which
means
giving it away so i joked that it was a
gambit in that i would get
compensation as a way of kind of trying
to overcome what happened and then it
just ended up growing from there
even though people use it mostly as a
joke okay so
hey magnus carlson botes gambited like
two weeks ago it happens to everyone
that's what i'm saying
oh no you're hiding behind carlson now
right okay
so isn't the question you accidentally
gambit your queen but do you come out on
top at the end
it's interesting i actually played some
games where i would give it up on
purpose to see what my rating was
without a queen against somebody my
rating and it was like a class a player
without my queen
okay yeah so that was pretty decent
okay that's good that's good now i heard
wasn't there uh that's the equivalent of
playing with one
arm tied behind your back please see two
arms because it's your most valuable
piece
all you can do is bite them exactly
oh my god that's hilarious well so so uh
i had i had my son
do some checking on you and so he dug up
a
series of games you played where every
game
your opponent you played someone better
than you
so you put you introduced some kind of
handicap so they introduced
the botez handicap on your opponent and
so if i
remember this correctly your opponent
had to
sacrifice the queen within the first 10
moves of those games
did i get that yeah that that was
exactly what we did that's hilarious i
know
it was so much fun but he actually
prepared for it
he used a computer to find the best
lines to sacrifice your queen
so that they're actually things that he
could play and win it was fantastic
do you take that as a compliment oh that
somewhat for sure that someone goes to
that length to just say right
actually it's just a competitive chess
player in him he wanted to win the match
so whatever it takes
yeah plus that that's just got to be fun
to watch right
and and just to follow it and you cheer
on and i bet
uh people i mean are there many chess
trolls out there or is it all just in
good fun
i i think there's a lot of chess trolls
i mean
when you look at the chess.com chat room
i love chess.com but it reminds me a
little bit of what you'd find in like an
online dungeon or something
oh okay wow
wow i love it please don't drop me
chest.com
hey listen we got your back we got you
back you're not made in the comments
you're just reporting
exactly exactly so um what did you major
in in college i studied
international relations with a focus on
east asia because i wanted to do u.s
china policy
wow look at you going all condoleezza
rice
oh wow she because she's she's she's
stanford
right oh she's matched they took her
back yeah okay she was international
relations as well exactly do you do so i
said that i said they took her back
do you play go i've never played go i'm
worried that if i try another strategic
game
i'll get addicted and then i won't get
better at chess
well i mean you've got a handful of
devious strategies well i say that more
than a handful i'm sure
for chess i'm dare say you'll create
something for a game like go
i mean most of my devious strategies
come
within the frame of time game so if it's
a one minute game
i do come up with a lot of tricks
because it's almost as if
there's some luck involved you can guess
that your opponent might make a mistake
just because they don't have time
right oh interesting so so okay so you
should now publish a book called
you know the book of uh boteztrix i
could and i think i would make a lot of
people upset on the internet
because people get really upset when you
dirty flag them
okay what is a dirty flag when you make
your opponent run out of time in a
position they're completely winning
oh okay okay so if it's a timed event
who cares
that's what i say i said it's within the
rules i'm not doing
anything wrong there you go it's you
went four corners on them
yeah like they're like you can't do that
you can't
okay so how much how much uh i have to
ask just because
that is what we do here um other than
your chess
geek underbelly did you have any other
geekiness were you a star wars or
you know did you like physics or math
anything like
total card carrying geek i i was always
just really nerdy i
loved school so much because school was
like a game
you know what your why is your why is do
the best in school because it helps your
life
so i would go and study by myself i mean
i came from
a really poor middle school my family
were immigrants so we didn't have a lot
of resources so i spent
all of my free time just studying for
the classes that i was taking
wow okay so you know what yeah there are
kids right now
watching this going god i hate this game
and they're watching saying
that's exactly right that's how that's
how you break the code that's how you're
going to
you've got you've got a big gig now
you've have you just signed with
uh yeah yes we just signed with envy
i mean congratulations you and your
sister well yeah there it is
absolutely yeah can you explain i mean
not the finances but
how all of that is going to pan out
because this is esports
legit yeah are you going to be now are
you going to be doing
esports chess or is it going to be
competitive
chess as watched on the internet
here's what i think it should be and
then you answer i'm thinking you should
they should let you do whatever the hell
you want yeah it just now has a more
visible platform
because they're only interested in you
because of you doing what you wanted to
do
well that would be that that would be
smart and then you lead the entire
creative presence on the internet so
what's what's going on that's actually
exactly what they want to do so they're
already esports champions they've won so
many titles in different games
and now what they want to do is they
want to help make the content even
better
so we have a ton of tournaments chess
related tournaments that are really good
and entertaining for the average person
and they're going to help with the
production
with getting it out to media with
helping our ideas come to life
and enjoy right because they've got the
resources to do that yeah so are you
going to
are you going to take this bullet chest
and
and and feature that because i'm going
to be honest of
everything that we talked about today i
mean you're talking about a 1500 year
old game
that has research that that has seen a
resurgence
i have never heard of this bullet chest
wait wait wait wait that's only one of
three or four fast chests yes words
right that's what
what are the others what are the others
bullet and blitz blitz
is over is usually five minutes or three
minutes
and there's also rapid which is usually
15 minutes
and it's something and regular chests as
well regular chest
is an hour and a half with 30 seconds
per move
and you usually get 40 minutes or 30
minutes after the 40th move so it could
last like six hours
yeah that's that's not the stuff but
this
that's that's not what they're buying
from you we can't watch more than 12
seconds
yeah we're not talking about that but
i'm just telling you right now this
whole idea of a game
lasting two minutes is
i mean i think you want to talk about
something that's compelling to watch
on screen that's an amazing uh
uh that's an amazing uh place think
about it chuck think about the landscape
for esports right now our drone racing
league guys our friends at the drone
racing league
those races last just over a minute
minute 10 seconds
so everything is snappy everything is
like really pacey so
this is a good one so alexandria we
interviewed uh a leading drone
racing champion and that's a whole other
esport
thing because it's all electronically
controlled we only have a couple of
minutes left
so alexandra have you thought of playing
quantum chess that's why i asked you how
much
physics geek is in you because quantum
chess sounds like if you if
if you get bored with chess and you want
to take it up a notch i i actually
watched videos on quantum chess and i
played
5d chests the thing is these variants
are so
hard to do well but they're very very
interesting and i did enjoy
wait what is five different chess is
basically you have
five planes of chess so you have to make
sure you're checkmating the person in
all of the different plates
if i explain that correctly wow okay
well that's that's two dimensions higher
than three yes
how how about the star wars how about
the star wars chess
are you have you ever played that where
your monster kills another monster oh i
saw that that was in that
graphics dad actually told me if i
didn't watch star wars as a kid i wasn't
his kid so
i'll have to check that out
yeah his highlight of the week is
watching mandalorian and sharing my mom
to my mom what baby yoda did
oh wow okay all right so it's that yeah
it's a good man
in the blood that's a good man that's a
good man so you played five
i i have crack team of researchers that
said you played 5d chess after three
beers
well yes that was not the best
preparation for the game i
admitted
um so so it's it's 3b 5d
that's that's what that's exactly
exactly so
so did the queen's gambit on netflix did
that influence you at all
and did you were you like me when i see
a sci-fi movie and so that couldn't
happen
that's not right they didn't do that
right i think they had some good
researchers on this but how would you
say overall they captured the reality of
chess this was the best depiction of
chess
on a screen ever whoa but yeah it is
okay
okay and it's not just me who thinks
this it's everyone in the chess
community from what i've heard so far
so this was just fantastic for that but
it was also super entertaining on top of
being accurate
what more could you want right yeah yeah
right and the lead actress in that she's
got those those creepy eyes was like
and i found out she's in she was in
horror movies before this one and you
look at her eyes it's like yeah
put that woman in her heart because she
feel no she's what she was i don't know
he's right he's absolutely i didn't
she's got this stare it's like you yeah
it's a great intensity for chess um i
actually watched her interview
she did an interview with judith polgar
the greatest woman to ever play chess
she was ranked number seven so she was
the only to ever break
top ten in the world and that was the
only part of the show that i would say
was inaccurate
yeah and it was basically i i i liked
that they didn't make it about being a
female in chess
but if you they did i i remember
thinking that exactly once they got past
the registration scene which was very
interesting uh yeah it was just here's
someone who who wants to win right
right um but but for example if you
would have thought in that time frame if
you're actually a female chess player
the first female to ever qualify for the
candidates which
the winner of competes for the world
championship was denied
being able to play because she was
female so if this was realistic
then you know beth armand would have
actually faced a lot more sexism
but what i loved about it is it shows
you what
it would be like to play chess if there
was no sexism involved and that is so
inspiring
right and so that becomes the standard
of how we all and plus all the people
who were sort of
trash-talking her for being female
became her close friends later on
and wanted to help her and she got
better than all of them so this if you
haven't seen the scene i highly
recommend it
well alexandra it's been delight to have
you on and we're going to keep following
your your career that you and that of
your sister and
uh good luck with your new uh your new
sports contract
yeah and maybe one day we'll find
competitive uh chess in the olympics
i mean we haven't had right now so
that's already pretty cool but thank you
so much for having me this was an
absolute pleasure yes
excellent excellent guys okay and uh
chuck always good to have you always a
pleasure and you're you're tweeting at
chuck nice comic
gary you're still tweeting at my
three left feet my three left feet and
what the hell that means and alexandra
just tell us where to find you
on twitch botez live b-o-t-e-z l-i-v-e
uh botes live and do you tweet
and yes alexandra v botes and and
uh instagram miss votes i wish i could
have had all the same names but they
were taken so alexander thanks for all
those handles
uh we can find everybody here on the
internet and do so you've been
watching possibly just listening to star
talk sports edition
gambits and game tv neil degrasse tyson
as always bidding you
to keep